après le triomphe de high school music
hall il est temps que je travaille sur
le spectacle du printemps prochain
joujou high school music hall de notre
high school est devenue légendaire
genève c'est toi zaki roj
denos rails zadi je dirige la petite
sirène pour danser c'est génial croisons
les doigts pour que les juges en disent
autant et si tu me l'as vous suivre il
s'agit du prix alan menken accordée à la
meilleure comédie musicale des lycées
vise la médaille d'or
bonne chance à vous tout ce qu'on dit
que high school music hall terre
adorable semestre nous allons concourir
pour le trophée à la même ken décerné au
meilleur spectacle davis et on nous
allons jouer la belle et la bête
pour nous cette relation à distance ça
va être trop petit la première chose que
je lui fais taper en fait j'ai été
accepté au conservatoire c'est très
important pour moi mais eric est aussi
est très important pour moi
est prêt à passer de comédiens amateurs
un tenant du titre du concours de telle
a toujours prédit salue les wildcats
vous devriez vous en tenir à ce que vous
savez faire là maintenant je suis un peu
effrayé car on est à his eyes on peut y
arriver
[Musique]
non ça y est du genre très imprécis ils
ont leur propre style de danse pour nous
l'essentiel c'est de ne faire qu'un avec
nos personnages aux personnages lumière
à mort
je sais qu'il ya des milliers de jeunes
qui rêverait d'intégrer ce conservatoire
mais il ya une chose qu'ils n'ont pas je
suis pas sûr de vouloir faire ça tout
seul on dirait que ta copine tu es
réclament un peu de liberté
ces mois ci une petite on cherche une
qui n'a pas besoin de jordanie j'ai eu
une impression de déjà vu
on tourne un mauvais remake djs
[Musique]
j'ai toujours adoré dans l'esprit de
compétition
va falloir tous si c'est la meilleure
école gagne accrochez vous les wildcats
c'est parti pour une année
extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]